bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat alors que les textes de
moralisation de la vie publique adoptée
en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale ont été gâchés par des débats
frileux et la levée de boucliers des
députés emmenés par le président de
l'assemblée nationale claude bartolone
qui ont tout fait pour empêcher la
publication du patrimoine des élus
c'est dans un tout autre état d'esprit
que les sénateurs examinent cette après
midi le projet de loi sur la
transparence de la vie publique
en commission ils ont en effet décidé de
supprimer les sanctions pénales pour les
personnes qui diffuseraient leur
patrimoine
alors sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle pour écouter la discussion
générale de ce texte bon après midi à
tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi organique et du projet de
loi adopté par l'assemblée nationale
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée relatif à la transparence de
la vie publique
la conférence des présidents a décidé
que les deux textes ferait l'objet d'une
discussion générale commune dans la
discussion générale commune
la parole est à monsieur alain vidalies
s ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
la parole monsieur le ministre
sur le président monsieur le rapporteur
président de la commission des lois
messieurs les sénateurs
rien n'est plus dangereux que
l'influencé des intérêts privés dans les
affaires publiques
ces mots de jean jacques rousseau tiré
du contrat social sont mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs l'esprit des
lois qui vous sont proposées aujourd'hui
je sais que beaucoup d'entre vous
j'allais dire d'entre nous s'insurge
contre les sondages qui révèle une
défiance grandissante inquiétante des
français à l'égard de leurs
représentants je sais aussi que la faute
de quelques uns ne peut emporter
l'opprobre contre tous les autres qui
exercent leur mandat dans le respect des
principes qui fondent leur engagement
j'ai la conviction que ces réactions
légitimes ne répondent pas à la tante
d'une opinion publique nourrie par le
doute à l'égard de ses représentants
alors que comme toujours en période de
crise
l'anti parlementarisme et au delà la
remise en cause des responsables publics
constituent le fond de commerce de
l'extrême droite
l'enjeu de ce texte est simple il s'agit
de retrouver le chemin de la confiance
de nos concitoyens de rétablir une
capacité d écoute de la parole politique
combattre le poison du soupçon permanent
par l' exemplarité républicaine
telle est la démarche que vous propose
le gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs g au
fil des semaines l'examen de ces textes
acquis une conviction sur ce monde
transparence qui attend cristalliser les
interrogations parfois les critiques
cette notion de transparence n'est au
fond qu'une des modalités d'exercice de
la souveraineté du peuple
car la démocratie c'est précisément la
délibération publique des représentants
et vu comme le pari de l'intelligence
dans nos concitoyens il s'agit pas là
d'une concession passagère à la mode ou
aux nouvelles technologies qui modifient
d'ailleurs dans un sens souvent heureux
l'information de nos concitoyens pour se
convaincre de l'ancienneté de cette
notion dans le débat public
il suffit de relire les débats tenus ici
même en février et mars 1988 lors de
l'examen de la loi dite de transparence
financière de la vie politique
présentait alors par le gouvernement de
jacques chirac jacques larcher était le
rapporteur de la commission des droits
est le journal officiel témoigne de
débats de haute tenue je citerai
l'exemple des brillantes interventions
de michel dreyfus mist ou de monsieur
lederman pour le groupe communiste
la lecture de ces débats m'amène en
outre à considérer que nul ne pourra
s'exonérer d'un constat qui est gravé
dans l'histoire des trois dernières
république
chaque majorité chaque gouvernement
souhaite légiférer dans la sérénité mais
il convient pourtant d'observer que tous
les grands scandales politico financiers
ont tous abouti à des modifications
législatives
sans remonter aux affaires des
républiques passé ni des temps antiques
il suffit ainsi de se rappeler que c'est
le scandale de la garantie foncière en
1971 qui rendit nécessaire la mise en
place du système de déclaration
d'activité faut-il également rappelé les
circonstances il conduisait le président
nicolas sarkozy a commandé un rapport à
la commission dit sauvé sur la
transparence de la vie publique rapport
qui demeura sans suite législative
parlant de la peste ce fameux mal
répandant la terreur est envoyé par le
ciel pour punir les hommes la fontaine
écrivait il n'en mouraient pas tous mais
tous étaient frappés
convenons que ce mot qui frappent
régulièrement la vie de nos républiques
et sans doute assez indissociable de la
condition humaine et du fonctionnement
des corps sociaux
convenons aussi qu'il nous appartient
collectivement
de lui administrer le meilleur des
remèdes démocratique la mode l'adoption
de bonnes lois qui seront bien
appliquées
le président de la république a demandé
au gouvernement de préparer et de vous
saisir sans délai de quatre projets de
loi
lorsque des événements récents que vous
connaissez impliquant un ancien ministre
du budget ont profondément altéré la
confiance des français dans leurs
représentants mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs la démocratie représentative
ne peut en effet se comprendre et être
accepté si ceux qui détiennent un mandat
du peuple exerce à leur profit et non
pour le bien des citoyens qui leur ont
accordé leur confiance nous le savons
les responsables publics de notre pays
ne manque ni d'odeur ni de vertu au sens
où l'entendait montesquieu mais je me
suis forgé une solide conviction à cet
égard au fil des mandats parlementaires
que j'ai eu l'honneur d'accomplir les
français ne pourront nous écouter si ce
n'est nous entendre qu'à la condition
que la parole publique retrouve son
prestige
il n'est pas la question des d'affaires
de partis de droite ou de gauche
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
démocratie est toujours une quête
permanente
elle doit se comporter par des pratiques
et des mars faisant davantage confiance
à la responsabilité de nos concitoyens
ces projets de loi font le pari de
restaurer la confiance dans les
institutions comme dans leurs serviteurs
en faisant précisément le pari de la
confiance dans nos citoyens depuis le
conseil des ministres du 13 mars
je travaillais déjà un projet de loi sur
les conflits d'intérêts sur la base des
recommandations du rapport de la
commission jospin mais surtout dans le
prolongement des engagements pris par le
président de la république en faveur
d'une république exemplaire pour ce
faire j'ai pris connaissance dès le
début de mes travaux de ceux de votre
commission et du groupe de travail
pluraliste institué en novembre 2010
sous la présidence
de jean jacques hyest ce rapport le
premier du genre est toujours une base
de réflexion indispensable pour
envisager le sujet qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui sur ce socle votre
commission des lois s'est donc attaché à
concilier plusieurs exigences légales
importance que ce soit la publicité des
informations et le respect de la vie
privée le contrôle par un organe
extérieur et la séparation des pouvoirs
ou l'indépendance de l'élu et la liberté
de mener une activité de son choix elle
a donc adopté sans amendement signe de
l'importance et de la contribution à la
qualité de la loi dont on sait qu'elle
est un souci permanent du président
sueur ces projets de lois s'organise
autour de trois objectifs de nouvelles
déclarations pour favoriser la
transparence démocratique de nouveaux
contrôles autour d'une autorité
administrative d'un nouveau genre des
dispositifs répressifs ou contraignant
moderniser le contrôle des électeurs sur
ceux à qui l'on confié le soin de les
représenter est une exigence
démocratique ancien ce regard citoyen
est l'essence même de la démocratie
représentative
je veux à cet égard vous rappeler qu'une
tête préoccupations apparaît dès l'aube
du régime parlementaire avec la première
assemblée élue au suffrage universel que
la france ait connu la convention
nationale c'est en effet le 14 mai 1793
que la convention décrété que les
représentants du peuple sont à chaque
instant comptable à la nation de leur
propre fortune
je cite la résolution révolutionnaire on
nous parle souvent de corruption et de
fortune scandaleuse pour connaître de
quel côté a été la corruption il est
demandé à chaque n'est que de chaque
député soient tenus de donner l'état
détaillé de sa fortune que cet état soit
imprimé et que celui qui aurait fait un
faux bilans soient déclarés infâme
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
cette exigence demeure d'une grande
actualité s'agissait donc de la
déclaration de situation patrimoniale
notre dispositif d'origine ambitieux a
été remaniée sur cette question de la
publication des déclarations qui a fait
l'objet d'un débat ces dernières
semaines se tient à rappeler qu'il ne
s'agit pourtant pas d'une question
récente si l'on veut bien se souvenir
que l'engagement numéro 49
parmi les 110 propositions de françois
mitterrand
prévoyez je cite la vie publique la vie
publique sera moraliser déclaration des
revenus et du patrimoine des candidats
aux fonctions de président de la
république de députés et de sénateurs
ainsi que des ministres en exercice
avant et après l'expiration de leur
mandat
ici même au sénat on relève dès 1979 une
proposition de monsieur mercier et des
sénateurs radicaux pour organiser une
telle publicité
des propositions de loi ou amendements
relatifs à ce sujet et maman de beaucoup
de groupes des groupes communistes
socialistes mais de beaucoup d'autres
furent également très nombreuses au
cours de ces 30 dernières années
nous y reviendrons dans le débat tout
enrobé en maintenant la publicité de
l'ensemble des déclarations d'intérêt
votre commission a donc modifié le
dispositif sur la publicité des
déclarations de situation patrimoniale
des élus est supprimé
l'infraction sanctionnant la divulgation
de leur contenu se limitant à pénaliser
une divulgation mensongères ou
délibérément inexactes nous aurons
l'occasion d'échanger à l'occasion
d'amendements qui ont été posées sur ce
sujet
la solution de compromis élaborée à
l'assemblée nationale permettez nous
semble-t-il tout en garantissant aux
élus au plan local la protection de la
vie familiale d'offrir de nouveaux
droits
concitoyens je pense là notamment au
droit d' alerte citoyenne qui est
maintenu mais sans la disposition
relative à la protection des lanceurs
d'alert dont on a vu à l'occasion
d'affaires récentes et je pense au
médiator par exemple combien il pouvait
avoir un rôle utile
la notion de lanceurs d'alert est une
idée relativement récente en france
j'ai bien vu que votre commission a
supprimé cette disposition auquel le
gouvernement est attaché
nous y reviendrons la commission des
lois un autre prévu le dépôt par le
gouvernement d'un document budgétaire
retraçant l'utilisation faite de la
réserve parlementaire l'année précédente
et a adopté à l'initiative de gaëtan
gorce des mesures renforçant
l'encadrement du financement de la vie
politique et des moyens de contrôle
ces évolutions ont le soutien du
gouvernement pour la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts nous vous proposons
également une avancée démocratique qui
fera date pour la première fois dans
notre histoire
un texte législatif va donc définir la
notion de conflit d'intérêt et mettre en
place des outils pour prévenir ce genre
de situation notre ambition est bien de
placer notre pays au rang des
démocraties les plus avancées en la
matière j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire en
commission des lois la question des
conflits d'intérêt est présente dans
l'ensemble des sociétés démocratiques
avancées
je sais que derrière les appréhensions
qui peuvent exister autour du terme du
mou transparence il y a en fait une
distance face à la notion de conflit
d'intérêts dans une société démocratique
avancée
c'est pourtant cette marge grise du non
droit qu'il faut faire régresser afin
qu'au lieu d'être ignoré certaines
situations soient organisées contrôlé
par le droit le gouvernement propose
donc que les déclarations d'intérêt soit
rendue obligatoire
pour les personnes visées par ce présent
projet de loi elles seront rendues
publiques par la haute autorité
je crois que l'on ne mesure pas les
bouleversements que cela induira votre
commission a remanié le contenu des
différentes déclarations cela me paraît
tout à fait utile et nous aurons
l'occasion d'en débattre
ce texte organise au surplus ce pour la
première fois un système de déport
imposant par exemple aux membres des
autorités administratives indépendantes
ne réduisons pas le débat aux seuls
parlementaires qui se trouve dans une
situation de conflit d'intérêts
l'obligation de s'abstenir de prendre
part à la sphère où la décision est en
cause il s'agit là une traduction
moderne de la maxime du droit latin
selon laquelle on ne peut être juge et
partie là encore cette nouvelle
obligation est la matrice d'un profond
renouvellement des pratiques
j'y reviendrai car le gouvernement s'il
a pris bonne note des interrogations de
votre commission quant à la situation
des ministres souhaitent une référence
explicite soit faite à leur situation
dans le texte le projet de loi institue
également un mécanisme nouveau de
mandats de gestion pour les intérêts
financiers détenus par les membres du
gouvernement et les membres des
autorités administratives indépendantes
intervenant dans le domaine économique
là encore quelle meilleure prévention
des délits d'initiés que ces mandats de
gestion sans droit de regard de la part
des intéressés
pendant toute la durée de leurs
fonctions afin d'assurer le contrôle de
ces différentes obligations
le gouvernement vous propose de créer
une haute autorité de la transparence de
la vie publique disposant de pouvoirs
effectifs et qui viendrait remplacer
l'actuelle commission administrative
institué en 1988 les principaux
responsables politiques et
administratives de notre pays devront
lui transmettre ses différentes
déclarations les sanctions pénales en
cas de non respect des obligations de
transmission seront renforcées
afin de mettre en place un véritable
organe indépendant de régulation
la haute autorité a est dotée de
l'autonomie financière et de la
possibilité de fixer son organisation
interne et ses procédures par un
règlement général le président de la
haute autorité sera nommé par décret
dans les conditions prévues par le
dernier alinéa de l'article 13 de la
constitution
nous aurons quelques échanges tenant à
la composition de ce collège puisque
j'ai vu que divers amendements envisagés
cette question la haute autorité aura un
rôle et des pouvoirs élargis au regard
des missions de l'actuelle commission
quelle est la valeur d'une règle lorsque
les moyens de contrôle soient n'existe
pas soit sont insuffisants je rappelle
ici que l'actuelle commission pour la
transparence dont certains demandent le
maintien avec le statu quo en droit
positif que cet actuel commission de la
transparence soulevé elles mêmes à
chaque fois au fil de ses rapports
annuels
l'insuffisance des moyens juridiques à
sa disposition pour remplir efficacement
la mission que le législateur lui avait
confié demain la haute autorité pourra
demander la transmission des
déclarations fiscales souscrite par le
conjoint
à défaut d'avoir obtenu directement
communication de ces déclarations la
haute autorité pourra en demander copie
à l'administration fiscale
la haute autorité pourra demander à
l'administration fiscale d'exercer son
droit de communication c'est évidemment
là une avancée très importante
une sanction pénale donne ans
d'emprisonnement et de 15000 euros
damende pourra être enfin prononcée en
cas de refus de communication des
déchets déclarations on le voit le
projet du gouvernement porte une réelle
ambition pour cette nouvelle autorité
administrative indépendante qui pourra
être saisi par le premier ministre le
président de l'une des assemblées
parlementaires ou une association de
lutte contre la corruption habilité
en troisième lieu la construction d'une
sculpture déontologique pour reprendre
les termes mêmes du rapport sauvé est
une tâche ardue qui suppose les
évolutions normatives que les présents
projets de loi vous propose nous vous
proposons deux séries de dispositions
tenant aux incompatibilités
parlementaire et un renforcement et l de
la répression contre les malversations
nous première proposition consiste à
protéger les parlementaires des intérêts
particuliers comme l'a rappelé le
rapport d'information sur la prévention
des conflits d'intérêts en mai 2011
la logique des incompatibilités n'est
pas d'interdire toute activité
professionnelle mais plutôt de
soustraire le mandat parlementaire aux
influences susceptible de l'écarter de
la prise en compte de l'intérêt général
le gouvernement propose donc d'interdire
par exemple le cumul du mandat
parlementaire avec des fonctions au sein
d'entreprises dont une part importante
de l'activité commerciale est entretenu
avec l'administration
l'indépendance des élus qui participent
à l'exercice de la souveraineté
nationale est un principe
constitutionnel qui doit être garanti
par l'édiction de nouvelles
interdictions qui évite la confusion
entre l'argent et la démocratie notre
commission a conservé les
incompatibilités parlementaire tel
qu'adopté par l'assemblée nationale en
ajoutant une nouvelle incompatibilité
avec la direction d'un syndicat
professionnel cela ce me semble
effectivement utile je tiens ici à
rappeler que tant en ce qui concerne le
contrôle de ces incompatibilités que les
sanctions éventuelles en cas de conflit
d'intérêts
le projet du gouvernement comme le texte
issu de votre commission respecte
pleinement l'autonomie des assemblées
car c est ce sera toujours le bureau des
chambres qui aura le dernier mot
sous le contrôle du conseil
constitutionnel
le projet de loi vous propose donc de
mettre en oeuvre l'engagement numéro 49
de françois hollande
anne ouvrant la possibilité à une peine
complémentaire d'inéligibilité afin que
l'ensemble des élus du suffrage
universel
les membres du gouvernement puissent
être condamné à une peine d'inégibilité
pouvoir être portée jusqu'à 10 ans en
répression des infractions portant
atteinte à la moralité publique tels que
la corruption le trafic d'influencé la
fraude électorale ou la fraude fiscale
nous vous proposons aussi de renforcer
la répression du pantouflage
l'interdiction faite par le code pénal
au fonctionnaire de rejoindre à l'issue
de leurs fonctions une entreprise avec
laquelle il était en relation du fait de
ses fonctions sera étendue aux membres
du gouvernement et aux titulaires de
fonctions exécutives locales
ces projets de lois s'attache à fixer un
cadre commun de la déontologie de la vie
publique s'enrichir dans le moindre
détail le comportement des responsables
publics
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
comme à l'occasion des principales
affaires qui éclaboussent r
les trois dernières république
l'inaction n'est pas une option en ces
domaines qui sont au coeur du pacte
républicain
l'ensemble des dispositions que le
gouvernement soumet à votre examen veut
servir la démocratie en lui apportant un
surcroît de transparence et de justice
justice sera d'abord rendus aux
responsables publics élus ou non en
réglementant les liens qui unissent
argent et politique ces projets de loi
veulent levée la suspicion qui pèse sur
eux
aux yeux de l'opinion publique justice
enfin pour nos concitoyens qui mieux
informés garanties pourront distinguer
le vrai du faux
sans le filtre du soupçon le nombreux
lycéens en plancher cette année sur un
sujet de philosophie suivant au
baccalauréat
peut-on faire de la morale
si l'on ne s'intéresse pas à la
politique
la question qui nous est posée d'une
certaine manière est inverse
peut-on faire de la politique sans
s'intéresser à l'amour à montesquieu
dans l'esprit des lois écrivait très
simplement que pour pouvoir fonctionner
une démocratie a besoin de personnalités
vertueuse je suis convaincu que la haute
assemblée sera promouvoir et améliorer
la cause de la vertu publique ce gros
merci merci monsieur le ministre
dans la discussion générale commune la
parole est à monsieur le président jean
pierre sueur rapporteur de la commission
des lois de la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
transparence le contrôle le respect de
la vie privée sont trois impératifs qui
s'impose à nous et nous revient à nous
législateurs de trouver avec le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre le
meilleur texte pour concilier la
nécessaire transparence le contrôle qui
s'imposent et le respect de la vie
privée auquel nous avons de bonnes
raisons d'être fortement attachés merci
jusque là je ne perçois pas de
contradiction merci
mais merci de bien vouloir mais goûter
le le présent texte monsieur le ministre
prévoit les obligations de déclaration
de l'ensemble des responsables publics
membres du gouvernement parlementaires
nationaux et européens responsables des
exécutifs locaux à partir d'une certaine
taille de la commune ou de la communauté
membres des autorités indépendantes
hauts fonctionnaires nommés en conseil
des ministres dirigeants d'entreprises
publiques afin de permettre la
vérification de l'évolution du
patrimoine pendant un certain temps
en tout cas pour les élus pendant un
mandat ou pour les fonctionnaires
pendant la période durant laquelle ils
ont exercé leur fonction est de montrer
qu'il n'y a pas d'enrichissement
inexpliqué cette loi s'inscrit dans une
lignée de loi monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez fort bien dit je rappelle que la
loi de 1972 à instaurer la déclaration
d'activité
je rappelle que la loi organique de 1988
instaurer la déclaration de patrimoine
et je rappelle que 7 en 2011 à
l'initiative des assemblées
parlementaires et tout particulièrement
du sénat qui a été instauré la
déclaration d'intérêts donc il y à une
évolution historique dans laquelle ce
projet de loi s'inscrit
je voulais aussi rappelé que la
commission du loup des lois du sénat a
produit un rapport qui a été rédigé par
nos collègues jean jacques hyest alain
anziani
nicole borvo pierre yves collombat yves
détraigne et anne-marie escoffier jean
pierre vial ce rapport qui a donné lieu
à un travail important dont les
conclusions ont été approuvés par la
commission m'a servi de fil rouge dans
ce rapport aussi ai-je repris dans les
amendements que je vais vous proposer un
certain nombre des suggestions qui ont
été émises dans le cadre pluraliste qui
a permis la rédaction de ce rapport
donc jusque là mes chers collègues il y
à une démarche des élus que nous sommes
attachés à la république et attaché à la
transparence au contrôle et au respect
de la vie privée oui monsieur monsieur
longuet
le contrôle du parlement par le
parlement c'est une bonne chose
la séparation des pouvoirs aussi oui je
vous ferai aussi remarqué qu'il faut
permettre que le contrôle aille jusqu'à
son terme et qu'à cet égard des
autorités indépendantes et d'ailleurs la
justice
la justice est la première des instances
indépendantes dans ce pays
du moins voulons-nous le croire eh bien
il faut que cela fonctionne sans qu'il y
ait monsieur longuet d'esprit dans
lequel une instance ne se réfère qu'à
elle même
il y a plusieurs débats sur lesquels
nous reviendrons longuement mais je
voulais insister sur certains de
certains d'entre eux d'abord la question
de la communication des déclarations de
patrimoine
il est bien que des déclarations de
patrimoine soit fait et vous remarquerez
que là le projet de loi prévoit dans les
détails
comment seront rédigées les déclarations
de patrimoine et nous avons à cet égard
adopté beaucoup d'amendements
nous en avons environ peut être encore
certains ce soir ces déclarations de
patrimoine sont déposées au début du
mandat à la fin du mandat
toute évolution significative monsieur
bel et doit être déclaré et comme vous
le dit très justement c'est déjà prévu
par la loi
très bien
ce qui n'est pas prévu par la loi c'est
la transparence
la communication des déclarations de
patrimoine
le projet du gouvernement prévoyait pour
les parlementaires comme pour les
ministres la communication la publicité
de ces déclarations de patrimoine
nos collègues de l'assemblée nationale
ont adopté un dispositif dans ce
dispositif
il est prévu que les déclarations sont
faites auprès de la haute autorité et
que la haute autorité transmet celle ci
après vérification et la commission des
lois a fait en sorte que les délais
soient revues de telle manière qu'il y
ait effectivement vérifications mais la
vérification pourra de toute manière
continue et après la transmission de ces
déclarations aux préfectures et selon le
dispositif adopté par l'assemblée
nationale
ces déclaration en préfecture sont
consultables par tous les lecteurs
nous vous l or la l'assemblée nationale
a prévu un dispositif en vertu duquel le
fait je cite la lina 51 de l'article 1
de la loi organique
le fait de publier ou de divulguer de
quelques manières que ce soit tout ou
partie des déclarations de situation
patrimoniale ou des observations ou
appréciation afférentes se traduit par
une sanction qui peut aller jusqu'à un
an de prison et 45000 euros d'amendé
je vous dis tout de suite que notre
commission a adopté un amendement qui
supprime cette à lignières pourquoi je
veux vous dire mon cher collègue parce
que parce que non non pas du tout
monsieur longuet je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ce que vous dites je ne suis pas du
tout d'accord avec ce que vous dites
l'honneur d'un parlementaire a beaucoup
d'importance mais seulement nous pensons
nous avons pensé à la commission des
lois et une très large majorité
nous avons pensé qu'il n'y avait pas de
sens
pas de fondements a sanctionné d'un an
de prison et de 45000 euros d'amendé
quiconque aura communiqué quelque chose
qui est universellement consultables si
tout le monde peut consulter si tout
électeur si tout électeur mais est-ce
que vous me laissez parler de temps en
temps monsieur longuet je vous en
remercie
si tout électeur peut consulter à la
préfecture ce cette déclaration il n'ya
pas pour nous de fondement à ce qu'il y
ait eu une telle sanction pour la
communication de ce qui sera de toute
façon publique pourquoi
parce que parce que la réalité du monde
dans lequel nous vivons
c'est qu'il existe des sites internet
dans le monde entier qui ne sont pas qui
ne sont pas régis par la loi française
si quelqu'un si quelqu'un pense ici
qu'il peut y avoir un dispositif mon
cher collègue pour que tous les sites
internet du monde soit régie par la loi
française
je le remercie je le remercie bien
vouloir m'indiquer lequel et d'autre
part il existe le secret des sources des
journalistes qui pourront très bien les
invoquer pour diffuser communiquer
largement sur ce à quoi chacun pourra
avoir accès par conséquent nous n'avons
pas retenu cette aligna 51 mais en
revanche nous avons adopté un autre
amendement que je proposais qui
sanctionnent fortement le fait que l'on
publie des déclarations mensongères ou
avec la volonté délibérée de nuire mais
mes chers collègues
êtes vous favorable au fait
mais êtes-vous favorable monsieur y est
au fait qu'on publie des déclarations
mensongères sans qu'il y ait la moindre
sanction
et bien évidemment que vous n'êtes pas
favorable avec cela alors mes chers
collègues vous vous verrez écoutez vous
ferez des propositions vous ferai des
propositions
j'ai déjà vu les propositions je n'ai
pas vu beaucoup d'alternatives
il existe une possibilité on en a parlé
encore ce matin c'est le texte initial
du gouvernement à savoir la
communication par le journal officiel
c'est une possibilité elle existe en
effet il existe une deuxième possibilité
c'est le dispositif qui a imaginé
l'assemblée nationale mais dans ce cas
nous pensons que la sanction qui a été
imaginé par l'assemblée nationale est
totalement disproportionnée et dans les
faits
n'est pas praticable et ne sera
d'ailleurs jamais ou rarement ou
rarement infligée en plus des sanctions
fortes
mais justifié de la part des
parlementaires à l'égard des parts il ya
des sanctions fortes les justifier à
l'égard des parlementaires qui ferait de
fausses déclarations ou qui omettraient
de faire ces déclarations je crois que
là-dessus il n'y a pas de désaccord
pour ce qui est bien pour ce qui est des
mini c'est dans la loi monsieur doligé
vous l'avez bien vu c'est dans la loi
pour ce qui est de l'inégibilité nous
nous sommes opposés à l'idée d'une
inéligibilité perpétuelle considérant
que c'était contraire à l'esprit de nos
institutions ne pensons que chaque
personne doit avoir le droit de
s'amender quelques décennies après on a
le droit de devenir meilleur alors c'est
dispositif s'applique aux parlementaires
aux maires des communes d'une certaine
importance et aussi aux présidents
d'intercommunalités on avait il était
inscrit dans le texte de la prop du
projet de loi 30 mille habitants nous
avons repris 30 mille habitants le
nombre total de personnes assujetties à
ce dispositif serait de l'ordre de 7
milles
mes chers collègues eux nous avons
également eu pris en compte monsieur
baylet eux la nécessité eu de préserver
la vie privée par rapport aux 1 division
en cas de communauté de biens
nous avons aussi soutenu ou préciser un
certain nombre de mots
ur relatives à la discrétion nécessaire
à l'égard des conjoints des membres de
la famille des proches
pour ce qui est des collaborateurs
parlementaires
nous avons souhaité préciser que devait
être déclaré les autres emplois qu'ils
exerçaient concomitamment le cas échéant